one of the many delights of using a
microscope
is that second before you peer into it
when you are only a breath away from
seeing
into another world and uncovering
organisms
familiar and unfamiliar
that moment is full of mystery what will
you
find this time an amoeba under attack
a tardigrade orgy or perhaps
an understated calming minute of
oscillatoria
sliding across the scene in that moment
anything is possible
[Music]
but sometimes there are clues even
before the organisms come into focus
like a whiff of something a little
smelly
that alerts you to signera blooms or in
the case of lacrimaria allure a ciliate
whose name
translates to tears of a swan what
you're looking for
is a wanton path of destruction
in a 1911 paper in the journal of animal
behavior the scientist
s o mast described lacrimaria as quote
among the most interesting of living
beings
now i'm sure we all have our biases
about what the most
interesting living beings actually are
and on the surface
lacrimaria don't necessarily seem
inherently more interesting than any
other organism
sure they're ciliates but so are plenty
of other organisms also
they get to be around 100 micrometers
long
they have both macronuclei and
micronuclei
and some contractile vacuoles which
again
is all very good but none of those
details
make lacrimaria particularly interesting
no i mean what we really want to know is
what's going on with that neck the
lacrimaria's
teardrop shaped body extends off that
neck like thing that has a sort of head
at the end of it obviously this head and
neck are not actual heads and necks in
our bodily sense of the words
but the structures are distinct and so
the terms are convenient ones for us to
use here
and what makes the lacrimaria's neck so
remarkable
is just how long it can get
sure the microbe may be named for a swan
but in his paper
mast notes the more obvious animal
comparison
punching the number is to see how
alacrimari's neck
compares to that of a giraffe he writes
as dismissively as one can in an
academic paper that a giraffe
has a neck that is scarcely as long as
its body
by contrast the lacrimaria's neck can
reach anywhere
from seven to eight times its body
length
as mast goes on to say if a giraffe
could pull off such a feat
then we would quote find the giraffe
browsing leaves from the tops of trees
well towards 100 feet in height
plus the lacrimaria's neck is just
so flexible able to wind itself around
debris in a way a giraffe definitely
could not but where giraffes use their
relatively shorter
and stiffer necks to forage through tree
tops lacrimaria
are much less vegan using their neck
to ambush prey alacrimaria's hunting
style
is incredibly successful
but it's built in part on
chaos instead of lying in wait for food
to come by
the lacrimaria plays the odds it
zaps its neck out incredibly fast
sub-second
movements to whip around and randomly
sample the area
around it for food this strategy
helps the lacrimaria capture all sorts
of prey
and that's why when you're looking down
at your slides you might see the damaged
remains of the lacrimaria's unfortunate
victims
before you see the hunter itself
if we saw this kind of carnage on the
savannas of east africa
pieces of animals strewn across the
landscape
none of us would ever get within a mile
of a giraffe
ever again when the lacrimaria finds its
target
it fires off a set of organelles called
extrusomes
to release toxins into their prey and
you can see that the flexibility of the
lacrimaria's neck comes in handy
not just for hunting but also for eating
expanding as it does here to contain
the entire meal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and even if the prey is larger or faster
than the lacrimaria and it can't get the
whole microbe
it can still tear off quite a sizable
chunk
and make a nice meal out of that piece
of course all that movement is a lot
and it's not something that the organism
can be doing all the time
our master of microscopes was excited to
find some of these lacrimaria so he
could observe them in action
only to find that they'd become much
less active their necks would pull
further and further inward until it was
retracted
entirely and then the ciliate itself was
completely still
lacrimaria are rare enough to find as it
is
and when james saw this strange
stillness
he was worried that he might be doing
something that was hurting his
precious friends months later he found
some more lacrimaria alor
but after 10 minutes of watching them
they did this same weird
dormant pose thing again concerned again
that he might be killing them james
left the slide in a humidity chamber
overnight so
imagine his relief when the next morning
he found that the slide was
full of reproducing lacrimaria
that's when james noticed that this
activity and dormancy
seemed to be a repeated cycle the
lacrimaria
would awake and be active for about 10
minutes
and then retreat back to their inactive
state for another 10 minutes and then
become active again scientists studying
this phenomenon have used
high-speed cameras to find that
lacrimaria cycle
between four total states there's an
active state where the microbes neck is
out and about to find some food then
there's a resting state where it all
retracts
and then there's an activation and an
inactivation state that transitions the
microbe between
active and resting possibly allowing for
the structures
underlying the neck to rearrange as the
lacrimaria moves from
one way of life to the next and so while
it's resting the lacrimaria is much less
of a threat
its neck which again is not actually a
neck retracts
leaving its neighbors in a moment of
peace but
when it awakens it will return to
twisting
and turning and elongating menacing the
microcosmos
until it has made a meal of it
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us
if you are a us citizen and you want to
not only keep imagining the world
complexly but also
have a voice in your government check
out how to vote in every state
the rules for voting are different
depending on where you live
so we've made a whole series of videos
explaining how to get your vote on
in each and every state as well as some
advice for special cases like
territories and overseas
voters this year we also put together a
guide for first-time
voters with help from our friends at
mediawise
to help you navigate everything from
your news diet
to political ads to money in politics
you can find all that
over at youtube.com how to vote in every
state
thank you as always to all of the people
on the screen right now
they are our patrons on patreon we have
two
patreon tiers now a two dollar tier and
an eight dollar tier so go on over
to patreon.com journey to micro if you
want to be one of the people
who make it possible for this show to
exist at all
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james check out
jam and germs on instagram and if you
want to see more from us
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby